fourth of july celebrations in a north
las vegas neighborhood turned
deadly two men are dead and others are
injured after a shooting late last night
this happened on helen avenue near cary
and martin luther king boulevard
kate houston spoke to neighbors who say
the escalation of violence
is worrying the community
here you can see police tape is still up
from last night's shooting one neighbor
tells me that the fireworks were so loud
last night they couldn't even hear
gunshots
after hours of fourth of july
celebrations police were called to the
neighborhood just after 11.
neighbors say they saw a swarm of police
cars and a crowd of people running from
parties
north las vegas police say seven people
were injured and two men believed to be
in their early 20's
died nicholas powell and lila hampton
say this is a tight community
and while they've had shootings and
drive-bys before nothing compares to
this
for me the sad part is knowing that
there's other families out there that
are going to wake up and realize
that their family member is not coming
home this is tragedy
every time you turn around someone is
getting killed or something somewhere
monday afternoon detectives were
canvassing the block which was filled
with used fireworks and party cups
they're pursuing all leads anyone with
information is asked to call the north
las vegas police department
kate houston 8 news now